This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, four
post-doates in pathology, naturopathic
doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care phys.
>> Hello and welcome everyone. My name is
Ruth Ellen Sanchez and uh let's go ahead
and open up that Zoom room door and let
people in. I am going to be your host
today. I'm filling in for Rebecca Dukes
while she's out traveling. So, big shout
out to Rebecca Dukes. Hope you're having
a great day. Um today we have a um a
really good show with Sher Browning and
she is going to talk about the living
table and rediscovering
um oh gosh fermented foods and the way
that people used to preserve their
foods. Anyway, um
I need to say this for legal reasons.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
treat, diagnose, or cure any diseases,
nor is it intended to take the place of
your primary care physician. The
statements in this program have not been
evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials are
shared as individual experiences of the
individual. Results may vary and are not
typical.
We do not make any claims regarding
health, income,
or anything else. As an empowered
individual, you have options.
So, I am going to go ahead and bring
Sherry up on the screen with me and we
are going to just get started. And
Sherry, when you get here, I would love
to hear a little bit about you.
>> All right. Well, I'm Sherry, as you
heard. have been with you guys for a
couple years now. What? Three, four
maybe? I can't remember. It's been a
while.
>> Three.
>> But I am a certified health coach like
the rest of our team members are. I'm a
mom, a wife. We had eight children, have
eight children. They're still here. And
um kind of traveled the world. But my
love is really
health and well-being. I'm one of the
oldest in my group that I hang around
with and I can keep up with everyone and
it and I can say it's because of
Youngevity because that made a a major
change in my life. I've been a health
coach since 2015
working with people, but it wasn't until
we introduced Youngevity products to
these people that it made a major change
in their life and mine as well. And they
still love it. These clients that I've
had for a long time are still clients
and they love the change that has taken
place since they started taking
longevity and living eliminating the the
bad foods that Doc Wall talked so much
about.
>> Thank you Shar.
>> I know helping people is your passion
and you've been an educator. U you're an
herbal teacher. You teach how to make
tea and different things like that,
>> right? I actually I I taught health
community classes for about 12 years and
ran workshops on how to make fermented
food, kombucha,
um any kind of fermented food. I taught
weight loss classes, just a little bit
of everything. It's a lot of fun.
>> Awesome.
I I wish I could live closer. I would
attend any class that you have in the
future. So, that would be great.
>> Well, thank you.
>> All right. I'm gonna turn it over to you
and you can Okay. I can't wait to hear
what you have to share. Thank you so
much.
>> All right.
Thank you. Well, I'm really happy to be
here and I'm happy that you've joined us
because we have a lot to learn about
today. If you haven't had the
opportunity to enjoy fermented food, or
maybe you have and you don't know it, I
want you to think back on what you had
to eat or drink today. Maybe a cup of
coffee, maybe some yogurt, or even a
piece of dark chocolate. You may not
realize it, but you've already
experienced fermentation because those
foods are fermented. Most people hear
the word ferment and they just picture a
sour pickle. Well, that's way beyond
that. At its core, fermentation is
beautifully simple. It's when friendly
microbes like bacteria and yeast get
together, breaking down sugars and
starches. As they do that, they create
natural acids that help preserve the
food. And more importantly, they
transform it into something new. In a
way, I guess you could say it's where
life creates even more life. It's
beautiful. Long before we had
electricity, refrigerators, or chemical
preservatives, we had microbes. We've
always had microbes. And for our
ancestors, fermentation wasn't a trend.
It was a necessity. It was the only way
to make sure the summer harvest could
feed a family through a long cold winter
when fresh food was scarce. And what's
really amazing is that every culture
around the world developed its own
version of this. In China as far back as
7,000 B.CE, and that is a long time ago,
people were fermenting rice and honey
into drinks. In Eastern Europe, nomadic
tribes discovered that milk carried in
leather bags would naturally ferment
into kefir, a drink they valued so
highly they called it a gift from the
gods. And I agree with them. In Korea,
kimchi was so important that families
would bury jars underneath the ground to
keep them as at just the right
temperature throughout the winter. and
incur and and in places like the
Philippines and Japan, fermenting fish
and soybeans provided essential protein
and salt that help people stay nourished
and strong. But then unfortunately
around the middle of the 1900s, we moved
toward canned and pasteurized foods.
We started caring more about how long a
food could sit on a shelf than what you
might call its the food's life force. We
traded complex fermented flavors for the
consistency of vinegar and sugar. Today
we're finally realizing just how much we
lost in that trade. And I think most of
you after hearing what we are going to
learn today would agree with that. And
if you haven't enjoyed fermented foods,
I hope today will inspire you to want to
do that. So why should we bother eating
fermented food?
Because fermentation does something no
other cooking method can. It often makes
food better for you than it was when it
was fresh. You know, it actually
increases the nutritional value of the
food. The raw food is is here. It can go
up as much as 300% or more in
nutritional value when you ferment it.
These microbes act like a tiny kitchen
crew that starts breaking down your food
before you even eat it. They take care
of the tough to digest components. For
example, they consume lactose and milk
to create yogurt, which is why many
people who struggle with dairy can
tolerate yogurt or kefir.
Second, fermentation turns food into a
kind of nutrient factory. These microbes
are hard workers. They actually create
nutrients like B vitamins for energy and
vitamin K2 which is vital for your heart
and bones but not easy to find
unfortunately in our modern diet.
And then there's the gut brain
connection.
We now understand that around 70 to 80%
of our immune system lives in our gut. I
like to think of our gut as a garden. So
let's just picture it as a garden.
When we eat fermented foods, we give it
prebiotics and probiotics. Now, the
probiotics are the beneficial bacteria.
They're like a seed or new workers
you're introducing to the gut.
Prebiotics are the fertilizer feeding
and strengthening the microbes that are
already there. Even more amazing, your
gut and brain are always talking. about
90% of your serotonin, you know that
feelgood chemical that your body
produces is created actually made in
your gut. So a happy gut usually means a
happy mind. It's very important.
Now how do you get started? The beauty
of fermentation is that it meets you
wherever you are. You can either become
the chef in your own indivi invisible
kitchen or you can let the experts do it
for you. If you're a DIY person like I
am, making your own ferments is
incredibly rewarding and very
inexpensive.
The price of a head of a cottage of of
cabbage, I'm sorry, the price of a head
of cabbage and some salt. With that, you
can make enough sauerkraut for a month.
Just one head of cabbage. There's
something special about tending to your
own inner garden. Starting at the
kitchen counter, you control the
ingredients, the salt level, and how
tangy you want it to be.
And it turns your kitchen back into that
place of a slow traditional crafting
kitchen like our ancestors used to do.
They used to make everything.
But there is convenience in buying it,
too. If your schedule's packed or if
you're just not ready to have jars
bubbling on your counter yet, buying
Living Foods is a fantastic option.
So, what do you look for? We don't need
to be a scientist, but you do need to be
a detective. Avoid the room temperature
shelves. To get the health benefits,
head straight to the refrigerator
section in your grocery store or health
food store. Check the label. Look for
the words raw, unpasteurized, or
contains live and active cultures. If
the ingredient list is just cucumbers
water or water vinegar, it's a pickle.
If the label says it's cucumbers, water,
salt, and it's in the fridge, it's a
ferment. There is a big difference. Now,
there are some trusted brands that I
like to get. If I don't have the time to
ferment or if I'm traveling, there are
some trusted brands. There are wonderful
companies out there doing the work for
you like Wild Brine. They make good
sauerkraut.
GTS for kombucha. That was my very first
kombucha experience. I remember that. It
was so fun. Or maple hill for 100%
grass-fed bever. I adore beer. Adore it.
The bottom line is whether you buy it or
make it, the goal is the same. Getting
those friendly workers back into your
table and into onto your table into your
gut. Now, I have a tip. If someone ever
asked me which one is better, the
homemade, the storebought, well,
homemade is often more diverse because
it uses the wild microbes from your own
environment.
But a high quality storebought versions
are wonderful convenient way to ensure
you're getting your fork full, and I go
at least a fork full a day of your
fermented food.
Another key point that is is that a long
a little goes a long way. You don't need
a huge serving. I want you to think of
fermented food works best as a
condiment. Think of it as a condiment,
not the main event. Just a tablespoon of
real sauerkraut or a small glass of
kefir each day can begin to shift your
internal internal ecosystem.
And if you're new to these flavors,
start simple. A high quality yogurt or
mild kombucha is a great place to begin.
As your taste buds adjust, and it is
really different, you can explore
stronger flavors like kimchi or miso.
Very funny, one of my classes, I had all
these fermented foods out for everyone
to try. And I had one particular lady
that was there. She was very particular
about what she ate and she had very
sensitive taste buds. You went around
and tried each one. She said to me,
"Well, I did it. I don't know if I'll
ever do it again, but I tried them all,
Sherry, and they are very different.
I tried to encourage you. This is You
have to train your taste buds to really
like this and it will over time. One
taste is not enough. You have to do it
again and again and again.
So,
as uh
as I wrap up, here's a big idea I'd love
to you to take with you, and then we're
going to have a Q&A time because I want
to open it up. You're not just an
individual. You're an entire ecosystem.
Trillions of microbes call your body
home and they're working for you every
single day. They're all over your body
on the outside and they're all over your
body on the inside. Starting with the
mouth all the way down. When we bring
fermented foods back to the table, we're
doing more than adding flavor and they
are very flavorful. We're tending to
that inner garden. We're reconnecting
with traditions that supported human
health for thousands of years. So,
here's a simple challenge of for you
this week. Try adding just one living
food to your table. your gut, your
brain, and your immune system will be
will all benefit from it. So, all right,
Miss Ruthan, do we have any questions?
>> I didn't realize I was muted. I'm sorry.
Yes, we do.
>> Marilyn has a question for us. That's
great. Caroline, go for it.
>> I would love for you to tell us the
value of raw cave fear versus raw milk.
Do you know the difference?
>> I was hoping somebody would ask raw
kafir mean having just you call it
kafir. I'll call it kefir. Everybody has
this different pronunciation for it. So
you're talking about using raw milk or
regular milk for pasteurized milk for is
that what you're discussing your
question? Sure. The comparison of the
two specifically, even if you just went
raw milk versus raw cake beer
>> or you can do what you said, that's
fine, too. Both both things need to be
addressed. I think people aren't aware
of it.
>> I totally agree. And when I make kefir
and the reason I make it is because I
want to make it with raw milk because
raw milk is a living food. And I have
used all the milks. I've used the
pasteurized, the ultraasteurized. I've
even used goat milk. But I always come
back to the raw and there's a reason for
that. Um,
raw milk is a complete raw dairy is a
complete package.
It comes with its own built-in digestive
tools. It contains enzymes and lactase
which helps break down milk sugar and
lipase which helps digest fat. Now,
pasteurization uses heat to kill
bacteria, but it also denatures these
sensitive enzymes. When you use raw milk
for kefir or yogurt, you are keeping
those digestive aids intact, making the
final product much easier on the
stomach. Raw milk is a living food.
>> Yeah.
>> By itself is great, but when you ferment
it, you even increase its nutritional
value. just the last two weeks I went
and I drink only raw milk, only raw kick
beer, only raw cheese,
>> and I even got some raw uh cream,
>> and my energy levels have soared through
the roof in two weeks.
>> I know.
>> So, I I I recommend every all the
audience, everybody to try it.
>> All the enzymes are there, all the
nutrients,
>> stuff I found out. I did a little bit of
research on my own. There's even I found
out some extracellular vesicles that
actually promote your messenger RNA that
involve with your immune system and they
said that 60 to 90% is killed through
pasteurization
and homogenation
>> right and homogenation makes the
molecules when you homogenize milk it
makes the molecules even larger and your
body just can't use them. So we think
we're protecting but we're not. We're
hurting. We're we're creating a very
beautiful food into a dead food in my
opinion. It's just
>> so the pasturization, am I right? It
kills three of the necessary enzymes in
milk and one of them is lactase. So
that's why everybody's lactose
intolerant, right?
>> That's correct. That is correct.
>> Why why were um local people that
produce raw milk, why are they so
attacked? son. I don't care.
>> Well, unfortunately, we have laws that
has changed the way we do things. And
laws came about, probably needed at the
time, but no longer are needed, and they
haven't been changed. So, I can't go to
a store and buy raw milk. I have to go
to a farm and pick it up. There are some
states you can't even go to a farm and
pick it up. They can't even sell it to
individuals for human consumption. Well,
I have a local local health food store
near me called Sprouts and I never see
the raw milk. They have raw cafere but
not raw milk. But I did now go to
another market called Frasier Farms and
they offer even the raw cream.
>> That's wonderful. I love that.
>> I love that. I when I was visiting my
daughter in Florida, I went to a store
that sells raw milk and they had to put
on the label not for human consumption.
They could sell it, but it had to say on
that label for the milk, the raw milk,
not for human consumption.
>> But I wanted to tell everybody, I'm
feeling fantastic energy that I haven't
had in years, in just two weeks. And I
know you could say it's anecdotal, but
it's the only thing different that I've
done,
>> right? I know I had the same experience
when I started drinking the cafir that
or kefir I made with raw milk. I had
this really good feeling. And I mean
just I felt good on and then I found out
that that's what cafir means. It means
good feeling or feeling good.
>> That's what I know that
>> it's wonderful.
>> Thank you for asking that Marilyn. I
appreciate that.
>> Sure.
>> Thank you Marilyn.
All right. We have a qu a comment from
Tori on um
there we go. Uh Tori P 3378. Hello.
Thank you for watching out there in
YouTube land. Um Tori says, "I use wild
brine for kimchi."
>> Very good. And so you are making a
fermented food. I was going to ask, are
there some ferment favorite fermented
foods out there that people are doing or
making or eating?
>> Yeah, put it.
>> If you have a favorite, let us know.
>> Yes, put it in the chat, everyone. And
if you have a question, please feel free
to put it in the chat and we will ask.
All right. So, I do have a couple
questions that came in. Um,
one of them is, "How do I know the
ferment is safe and not just rotten?"
You know, this takes me back when I
first started fermenting. I was
petrified. I mean, literally, I was so
afraid to try anything, tasting thing. I
was so afraid. I mean, I was just so
worried about it. I didn't want to get
any horrible illness from it. And I
found out that I have never had any
ferment yet not turn out. Never. I've
never had it go bad. I've never had it
made me sick. And I I've been eating it
for years. So the answer is this.
Fermentation is a is controlled by salt
temperature or a specific starter if you
decide to use it.
>> So trust your nose. The nose knows
if it smells foul or putrid like
garbage, throw it out. If it smells
bright, sour, or tangy, that's a great
sign that it's working perfectly. And I
have always had them all turn out good.
It took a while to build up my
confidence about it, but now I never
think twice about it. I just It's
fantastic.
Any more questions? So, Zezy Captain out
there in YouTube land, hello. He says,
"Hello, Sherry and Dylan." Hi.
>> And he said, and Zezy Captain says, "I
don't drink the milk anymore. Only heavy
cream till I can find a farmer or
farmer's cow." LOL.
>> Good for you. Good for you.
I'm lucky that I live in Texas near
farms and I have this woman. and she's
in her 80s and she still milks cows,
brings them and delivers them at a
certain location where we all go to get
it from her so we don't have to go out
out to the farm to get it. And you look
at her and you think, there is no way
that woman is that old, but she is. And
she is fabulous. I usually buy three
gallons at a time. I make three gallons
of kefir at a time. That's how much I
drink.
>> I love that. I know you sent some kefir
grains to Miss Becca Dukes and when she
comes back we are gonna find a farm and
start utilizing those beautiful grains
that you sent us. We can't wait.
>> Very good. Very good. Excellent.
>> All right. And Nancy has her hand up.
Nancy,
do you like doing?
>> Okay. So, I also put this in the chat,
so disregard the chat. So my husband
when I went to go buy raw milk a couple
years ago, I came in late, but I had
heard that the reason people are lactose
intolerant is the molecule structure
changes,
>> but it had a big bold letters not fit
for human consumption.
Where would I find?
So it scared me. So I um I I pretty much
don't drink a lot of milk. Um, I drink
almond milk and coconut milk, all that,
but um
I I I would I would like to drink
regular milk and but I how would I is
there a I don't know if you've already
said it. Is there um a peer review or
like I got a like on John Hopkins I get
a lot of my information from there to
validate Dr. Wallock studies or do Dr.
Wallock stuff?
>> Do you know where I can get accurate
data or credi data with credentials to
overcome the argument in my home.
>> Well, yeah, that's I I just get out
there and search, go to PubMed and check
there all over the place. I am a walking
example of what it's like. So, I don't
need those studies to convince me
because I've been living that for years,
but I understand what you're saying,
Nancy. I totally get you. And you're in
Florida, so some stores will sell raw
milk, but it'll have to say not fit for
hum or not for human consumption. Um,
if you want Ronald,
>> go ahead.
>> I'm sorry. You go ahead.
>> Yeah, just do the research is out there.
I know it's out there. So, but there's
also a lot of misinformation is out
there. A lot of fear mongering is out
there. I don't know why people hang on
to it like they do, but they do. The
Amish don't pasteurize their milk. They
do everything raw, and they're doing
great. I think I think we have to get
over our fear. I had to and once I
started eating and drinking fermented
foods, that fear is totally gone now. I
fear more the fresh stuff that keeps
being pulled back or recalled by grocery
stores because of E.coli. I fear that
more than I do fermented food, quite
frankly.
>> Yeah. Does that answer your question?
>> Anything processed anymore? Even even
all the organic if it's in a bright
colored
carton. I'm I'm Larry.
>> But but don't be afraid to buy that
milk. They just by law have to put it on
you. That's the only way they can get
around selling it in a grocery store.
Don't worry about that sign. I bought
three bottles of that when I was at my
daughter's brought it back in a cooler
and I used it to make effort and I'm
still here doing just great.
>> So is there a lenus paper that you could
put in there? Maybe Olivia.
>> Not that I know of.
>> No,
>> you know, milk has its own way of milk
has its own guardians in there that
takes care of it. There was, let's see,
the enzymes help it. What's another
raw milk has um
it has its own crew that takes keeps
their milk safe. It's only going to be
unsafe if it's not handled properly. But
modern day farming is just not like
that. People are really careful. It's
not like it used to be when that law
came on the books. It's not at all like
that anymore. So don't fear it. Enjoy
it. God gave it to us.
>> Yes. Yes. I agree. It looks like Marilyn
has a question.
>> All right, Miss Marilyn.
>> More questions.
>> Yeah. What do you think? Uh Sherry, um I
recently too when I went to the Frasier
BMS, I found Dulce. It's a raw um
seaweed and I was always taking taking
nori and that's roasted and dried and
then I recently got some doulce and but
they said I have to keep rinsing it.
>> Now I have it it's tast it tastes again
not like nothing like nori like you it's
it's kind of weird taste. You kind of
have to combine your food. But here's
what I do with dull seaweed. Here's what
I do with dull seaw
pieces of seaweed that you can get. I
stick that in my soups and stews.
>> I just put in there and I let it cook
away and and just extract all of that
good iodine and all that other good
stuff out of it. And then I discard it.
I don't eat it itself. I just put it in
there to let it do its thing while the
food is cooking.
>> Oh, I've been eating I've been eating
it. Um I just
>> You can There's nothing wrong with it.
Absolutely. Can I ask you how long will
it keep? Like once you rinse it and you
put it in the refrigerator, if it's in a
tight sealed container, how long can you
keep raw?
>> You're probably going to have to open it
up and smell it. Uh if it's if it's damp
at all, it's going to start to degrade.
>> If it's that's why they they usually
market dried seaweed because it will
last longer and it's still good stuff,
too. It probably not a long time if it's
still damp.
>> And have you worked a lot with
mushrooms? They're selling a lot of
gummy mushrooms. Like
>> I have not I have not worked a lot with
mushrooms. I didn't like mushrooms for
years. My husband finally convinced me
to try them and now I do like them and I
eat them, but I don't do a lot with
them.
>> Okay.
>> They sell they're really expensive to
buy like mushroom gummies like like
might have lion's mane and maybe two
ingredients like B12 and folic acid, but
they want like $30 for a small amount.
Anyway, you might have Okay. Thank you.
>> We have a good product for that and
that's oceans gold. That's a good No,
that's not that's seaweed. That's not
mushroom. Trying to think of something
else.
>> We do have products with mushrooms in it
that are great.
>> Mushroom coffee and killer biotic and a
few other things.
>> There you go. So, we've got it.
>> Thank you, Marilyn.
>> Thank you, Marilyn. Appreciate it.
>> All right. Let's see.
Just checking
real quick. Okay, so another question
that we had is um somebody says, "I
tried fermented food, sorry, food, and
my stomach felt a bit bubbly slash
bloated. Am I allergic?"
Great question. No, you're not. This is
often what we call the Herxheimer
reaction, and it's just a die- off. So
when you introduce good guys to the gut
that isn't used to them, there can be a
little temporary civil war going on in
there and the bad the bad bacteria are
being pushed out by the good guys. My
suggestion is just to start really slow
every day. Take a little bit, maybe a
spoon, a small spoon a day and just go
slow and before you know it, you'll have
the good guys really have pushed all the
bad guys out. Your gut will be much
stronger.
>> Very good. I have I have noticed that um
sometimes when I start taking like the
nightly essence
>> probiotics and different things that
sometimes there's uh
an interesting thing that happens with
the body and especially I26
like you that that if you have bad
bacteria in your intestines
that and sauerkraut are great.
>> They sure are. Those I26 are going after
those those pathogens on I26 are going
after those bad things.
>> Very good. All right. So, we had another
question about um does freezing kill the
bacteria in fermented foods?
>> And that's a really good question. And
and actually, no, it doesn't kill it.
Not usually. I mean, I guess there could
have some times when that does happen,
but I haven't ever had that happen.
Usually when you take it out and you
thaw the food, the bacteria will just
your bacteria just start doing their job
again. It it slows it down really a lot
in the refrigerator. The the reason we
take fermented food that we're
fermenting on the counter and we move it
to the fridge is to slow down the the
process of fermentation. We want to slow
it down. We don't want it to keep going
or it just keeps going going going until
the point where you can't drink it fast
enough or eat it fast enough before it
becomes probably not too palatable.
So if you put it in the freezer and you
take it out, it's just going to it's
just slowed that process down a lot and
then when you thought it just starts
back again. Usually does.
>> Very good. Um it looks like
Okay, so Zezy Captain on YouTube is
asking
um
you might ask Sherry
what's her take on age cheese.
I only eat at least one year aed cheese
and if I find it helpful to my regular
eating schedule.
I love the aged cheese. That's fermented
cheese. That's why it's aged. It is
fermented. And when it's fermented like
that, your body can accept it better. It
can use it better. It can break it down
better. Those little microbes have done
their work and now you get to enjoy all
their work. I love a cheese.
>> Can you name a few cheeses that are aged
for us?
>> There would be some cheddars are aged
and there is what are the other one? The
other one is uh
what I had some written down here. So I
wouldn't forget them. I know cheddar
being one. I wonder what he eats. What
cheddar? What's type of cheese does he
eat?
>> He said aged cheese. You didn't
>> with cheddar or
or
Okay. So then the Tori
um Tori P 338 3378 on on YouTube. Hello
love Tori. um thoughts on using a good
probiotic like Youngevity Nightly
Essence or the new probiotic
from the Youngevity Hope bundle as a
starter. So, what are your thoughts on
those?
>> Okay, that's another really good
question because I have opened up those
capsules of the probiotics and used them
as a starter with um with when I'm
making a fermented food and you can do
that.
Those capsules though were designed to
open up in the warm area of your gut
instead of a cold area of a fermenting
dish. So if you put them in something
cold, they may not work as well. Not
saying they won't. They could, but they
were really designed to open up in that
warm environment in your in your gut.
So, you can you can buy starters that
have been made for fermented food and
they work really well in the cold
environment they're going to be put in
when you're fermenting. That's the only
big difference.
>> Perfect. Thank you.
>> And then um let's see, there was another
one.
Oh, Tori P, thank you for this
information. I couldn't remember the
name of the product. uh says that
Ultimate Microbiome has a mushroom blend
in it,
>> which right
>> has several of mushrooms in there and
that is really good.
>> And then
Oh, anyway. Okay. So, um
Marilyn looks like she has another
question.
>> This is wonderful, Marilyn. I bet you'd
be a great fermenttor.
>> Well, I've just been so excited about
this concept. It seems like God or
something the last couple months
bombarding me with the word raw. I don't
know why. It just keeps coming to me.
And um the yesterday I was looking for
raw cheese and I only saw and I and they
have multiple brands, so many hundreds
of brands of cheese and I only found
cheddar, Monterey Jack, and goat that
are raw. So there's no parmesan, there's
no ble blue blue cheese, there's no feta
cheese that's raw. Do you know why? And
if we can change that because I could
only find those three.
>> Just what the store is selling because
you can find those raw in some areas.
>> But that's just what that store is
selling. And maybe it was just because I
don't know. I when I buy raw cheese, I
know I have to use it pretty quickly
though because once you gr it,
>> it can start to grow green mold on it.
>> So you I freeze mine. I keep mine. I do
too. That's what I was going to say. I
freeze it and then I grate what I'm
going to use. But I've got to use that
grated cheese up. I can't just let it
sit there. You know, you can buy those
bags of grated cheese and leave them in
your fridge. You're not even And you go
back and they're still there and they
still look okay.
>> What are they putting?
>> Yeah, that's what I'd like to know.
What's causing it to last like that? It
shouldn't be. But if you grate the
really raw cheese and you don't use it
right away, about a week later, you're
going to see a mold start to grow in it.
So that then I throw that out. That's a
green mold. It's not a healthy mold.
>> I looked at all the labels and most I
looked at all the labels and almost all
the other cheese had it was pasteurized
or skimmed and not the fat milk.
>> Yes.
>> What I would like to know is if you can
find some raw especially parmesan
>> let me know.
>> I don't know. I don't know.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Probably ask your store
people when you go to these uh health
food stores or something and just say do
you carry do you have access to get raw
parmesan? Do you have it? See if they
do.
>> Yeah, because I've heard those three,
parmesan, the blue cheese, and the feta,
if we can get them raw, it I've I've
heard that it protects the cell wall,
which is your first line of defense
against immunity.
>> Germs.
>> I love raw food. Yeah, thank you.
>> I will.
>> Thank you, Marilyn.
All right. Um, let's see.
>> Ny's back,
>> huh? Nancy,
>> you see Nancy? She's come back. Hi, Miss
Nancy.
>> All right. Let me ask her to unmute.
There you go.
>> Okay. Okay. My understanding the
Parmesan cheese
it is grown only it is it is real
Parmesan cheese is in one place
somewhere in Italy and that they have a
lot of codes and laws surrounding the
Parmesan cheese. Now you have cheese
that they claim is treated like
Parmesan, but it's like a Valdea onion.
You can only get a Valdea onion that is
grown in Valda, Georgia. You get other
sweet onions and they may throw a name
on them, but genuine Parmesan cheese has
to come from that place in Italy. And
the wheels are well over $100,000 a for
a wheel. and they put them under lock
and key because people were rolling them
out and put them on trucks and stealing
them, but it's a highly regulated um
cheese parmesan is.
>> Thank you, Nancy. That helps us learn. I
appreciate you telling us. Thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> I don't know if it's healthy or not, but
it sure is good.
>> Well, you're sharing it with us and I
appreciate it.
Thank you.
All right. And Haddie, would you like to
unmute?
>> Oh, awesome. Thank you.
>> You're welcome.
>> You I I absolutely love um raw milk. Um
I don't know where to get it at where
I'm living at now, but I'm definitely
going to research it again. But I wanted
to know if you I believe you talked
about you had a recipe where you make
your own kefir. I would love to hear it
again.
>> Right. Lastly, since you were talking
about starters,
I need a starter so I can start making
my own gluten-free bread. There's always
wheat starters, but I don't want to do
that. So, just wanted to know since
we're talking about starters.
>> Well, I appreciate you asking that,
Hattie. There are people who are working
on formulating gluten-free bread using
yeast to make more of a sourdough type.
I haven't really worked on that. Years
ago, I used to make before I found
Youngevity and Dr. for a while like I
used to make sourdough bread and I loved
it but I don't do that anymore. So there
are people who are doing that and as far
as where's your other question Hie?
Oh. Oh the recipe for making kefir it's
very simple. You do need kefir grains
and they look Wish I had some in here.
They're in the kitchen. They look like
little pieces of cal cauliflower. That's
what they look like. They're white. And
um you just use a tablespoon of kefir
grains with a cup of milk. That's all
you do. Put them together in a jar, lay
the lid on top, let it sit 24 hours, and
you have your kefir. It is the simplest
dish to make there is.
Very good. Thank you very much. I used
to make sourdough. I had sourdough
starter. I'm trying to remember where I
put the recipe that I got, but you can
use a King Arthur gluten-free bread
flour as long as it has sor gum in it.
And I believe that it was
a third of a cup
to twothirds cup water and and then you
can um let it ferment on the counter,
but you have to feed it every single day
and stir it
>> every single day. And I will look for
that recipe and get that too. Um I'll
post it.
>> That was one of the reasons why I kind
of quit making sard because it's so time
consuming. Yes. And then
>> one of the things I wanted to make
>> and I made sourdough pancakes. Now those
were the bomb.
It was good. So I'll look for that and
I'll post it in the comments on YouTube
when I find it.
>> All right. I thought I saw another hand
up. Um Key had her hand up, but I don't
know where she went.
>> Is she still here? She is still here.
Did you want to come on and
uh unmute?
>> Yeah, I'm here. I was moving around.
Sorry. Um
>> uh for the one of the last questions
that was asked in reference to the raw
cheese, um you can find the raw cheese
at a lot of your specialty stores. Um,
and there is a um a raw farm brand and
you can get it in multiple different
varieties. You can we find it here at
Sprouts um and at Time Market. Um we
also find it at some of our farmers
markets and they'll have the raw guda
and cheddar cheese. So it is out there
and it is available all unpasteurized
just so you know. But one of the main
brands is Raw Farm USA
>> and they do your raw jack cheeses.
>> Good.
>> And then you have and then you have your
imported brands as well. The other one I
think it's um it's Organic Valley and
they do the sharper tasting stuff.
>> Okay.
>> Um so just to update you on that. The
other thing is is that you know you do a
lot of fermentation. How much canning do
you do in reference to that or do you
just all keep it raw? I mean,
>> I do canning because I love bone broth
and so I can all the time. Well, not all
the time. I when I get an accumulation
of bones, whatever it may be, chicken,
beef, or whatever, then I do can for I
make the bone broth and then I can it.
So, I do that. I don't can vegetables
much anymore because I have quite a few
in my my pantry. And I really do love
the fermented food. If I have, let's
say, Keely, I have a protein
and maybe I don't have a vegetable to go
with it. I will actually pull out a
couple spears and I'll show it what it
looks like. A couple spears of this is
okra. A couple of spears of okra and eat
that as my veggie. And I'm getting a
little bit of everything. I can I eat a
lot of fermented foods, so I can eat a
couple of those and it's just wonderful.
It's my vegetables and it's my fermented
food. So, do a little canning, but it's
mostly just broth now.
>> So, what would you say to parents that
have younger children that really, you
know, they don't like their veggies? How
do you get those fermented foods into
their, you know, menu?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'd probably start with the
kefir and I'd just make make it add
something to it to make it taste a
little better. I'd probably start there.
Or kombucha. Kombucha. When my
grandchildren would come visit, that was
their first word. Bucha.
Bucha. Mimi. Bucha. That's what they
would say when they came in the door.
So, that's another one to get started
on. It's an easy one. Just try to not
drink kombucha with your meals because
it is a carbonated beverage. It It's
naturally carbonated, but it can
neutralize your stomach acid. So, I
always would drink it away from meals.
Maybe an afternoon pick up around
three-ish or so and have a cup of
kombucha. I would do that. I would try
to get them
and start young. If you can get them to
have just a little bit of fermented
food, it's surprising how much children
will enjoy it more than adults will. So,
just give them a tiny bit on their plate
and say, "Just try that. See what you
think. Maybe a little bit of sauerkraut
or or whatever." And just see what they
think. And then get the fermented
pickles rather than the canned pickles.
Most kids love pickles. I'd put them on
that.
>> So, what was the what would be the
youngest age that you would introduce
them to? As soon as they possible young
as possible.
>> Yeah, as young as possible. I would
start them because we are training our
children's taste buds when they're
young. And so, if you get them started
right away, especially when they're, you
know, just experiencing food other than
mom's milk, um it helps train those
taste buds. And then you want them to
want the really good stuff. And if a
mother will really eat healthy when
she's pregnant and eat uh fermented
foods when she's pregnant, studies have
shown, I don't have them in front of me,
but studies have shown those children
are going to want that when they're born
because that's what the mother ate when
she was pregnant. I It's amazing.
And I do have a testimony to fermented
foods because my husband's Polish and
Slovenian. And I'm telling you what, he
has got an iron gut. Virtually is never
sick. And as soon as he is, he reverts
right back to a fermented food and it
leaves in a very short period of time.
>> Yep. Oh, I love it. I love it. I love
it. And the brine from your fermented
food, once you've eaten all the food out
of that jar, do not throw away that
brine. That brine is gold. You just
drink that. I mean, don't drink it out
the bottle, but pour it in a little cup
and drink it every single day. It will
help give you stronger stomach acid. It
helps get rid of the bad pathogens. It's
just it's gold.
>> And we've been throwing it away.
>> Don't you dare. Don't you dare.
>> Okay.
A friend got a bunch of chickens from
some place. I don't know. She deboned
them and she freeze-dried them. And I
said, "Well, what'd you do with the
bones?" Oh, I threw them away. I said,
"What? You should have made bone broth
out of it. Don't you dare throw them
away." No, drink that brine. Everything
in that jar, you drink.
>> Everything.
>> Everything you eat and drink.
>> Okay. Well, no more throwing that away.
>> That's right.
>> Thank you.
>> You're welcome, dear. Thank you for
asking.
>> Yes. Thank you. Yeah, that's um funny
because um my husband's Korean and he
was raised, you know, the first three
years of his life he lived in Korea and
they fed him kimchi.
>> Yeah.
>> From a very very very like very small
child and he would cry and freak out and
it burned his mouth and they would water
it down in the soup broth
>> and give it to him. He has a cast iron
stomach like
>> Yeah,
>> he can eat anything. And he
>> And that's real strong. That kimchi is
very strong.
>> Yeah. Very rarely get sick. And you
know, his mom used to make kimchi
um and we would get big jars like big
big jars of kimchi and um and we'd go
through it be in the refrigerator and
then he'd um you know give her the jar
back and um
>> I want more. Yeah. And then after she
passed away, you know, we had a couple
jars of her kimchi, you know, and um so
we ate on that for a while and then he'd
have to sometimes rinse it and start the
process over because it would get a
little like foamy kind of textured.
>> Yeah, it can. Yeah. Careful.
>> I see Albert has a question.
>> Yes, he does. But first, I want to say
one thing because I thought itly sweet
from Bruce.
for sure. You're awesome. He says,
"Jerry is a good piece of the puzzle to
Becca's team." Great team.
>> A thank you.
>> Thank you very
>> Hi, Albert.
>> Just going back to the the milk as a
young lad, I grew up on farm milk. The
milk we got for years and years and
years was still warm. And boy, did we I
dived into it. And we would get thick
layers of cream and you would actually
just take this let it dry a little bit
and you would take the whole skin off
the the the cream and you could just eat
it like it was magnificent.
>> Yes.
>> So I've had a lot of raw raw raw milk.
>> I'm glad to hear that. My father did
too. He was raised on a farm and they
always had raw milk. He never he never
had pasteurized milk until he became an
adult and was in the military. Yeah, I'm
glad to hear that, Albert. They do it
right.
>> And then on the fermented foods, I've
become well, I'm enjoying the cabbage
and garlic, but I've I don't know what
I've done is a few times I've tried to
make carrots and I've just destroyed it
and fed the I've fed the monkeys and the
baboons outside. So,
so what what would I have done wrong
doing the trying to ferment the carrots
that made them go off? And I followed
the same processes basically.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Maybe not. So, now carrots
have a more a more sugary base than
cabbage does and then garlic does. Your
carrots are going to have more sugar
inside, glucose inside. So, you probably
need extra salt.
Okay.
>> Make it really, really salty.
Try it again. All right.
>> Did you cut your cabbage? Did you cut
your carrots or did you shred them? And
how did you do it? No,
>> I cut them in long strips and I've put
them in a bottle. So, the idea was that
I would just be able to take them and
and nibble on them like that.
>> Okay. Try to cut them in like copper
pennies instead of long strips. Try to
cut them into copper pennies. See if
that works better.
>> I haven't tried the strips like that. It
may work. I'm not sure. But I always
make mine into either I shred it or I
put it into like penny size, you know,
coin size. You just chop the carrot like
that. Yeah.
>> And how long do you do you leave it
>> on the counter? Usually about four days,
five days at max.
>> So the same.
>> And what I do is I take the lid off and
I take a carrot out and I taste it. I
say, "Do I like this? Is it what I want
it to taste like?" If I say, "No, it
needs a little bit more time." I'll put
the lid back on. kind of let it ferment
some more and then I'll check it check
it again and if it has the crunch I want
which I want to keep having I want to
have crunch and has the flavor pretty
close to what I want then it goes in the
fridge
>> okay I'll try that
>> all right let me know how it turns out
Albert I'd love to hear
>> thanks Sherry
>> thank you Albert
>> and and Keley has her hand up I did have
one more question.
>> Okay,
>> that came in. Let me bring myself back
up here and then we'll go to Key. Um,
>> where is my question?
Um,
I thought I marked it. Oh,
why do you prefer raw dairy and Oh, you
know what? You answered this question.
>> I did.
Okay. So, um,
do I need to buy those expensive airlock
lids I see online?
>> Good question. Because they were I mean,
they're nice. You don't need them.
They're nice. The main thing is just to
keep the the fermented food below the
fluid, the liquid. That's all you're
really after. I don't buy them. I
haven't used them. I use I take a jar as
you see with a white lid and when it's
fermenting that jar is just sitting on
top like that. That's all it is. I don't
even tighten the jar so that the gases
can escape.
>> But I will go every day and push things
below the water line if I see that it's
sticking up. These aren't they're packed
in there real tightly so they don't they
aren't sticking up. And and I just leave
it like that. You don't have to spend a
lot of fancy money on fancy stuff. It
just isn't necessary.
And once it goes in the refrigerator,
you tighten the lid down.
>> Yep. Tighten the lid down and stick it
in the fridge.
>> Very good. All right, Key, I know you
had your hand up.
Would you like to unmute, please?
Unless she answered your question.
>> Uh, two questions. Uh, one is, um, do
you do any of your growing and
harvesting yourself?
>> I do. I do. These
These okra are from my garden. Oh, how
about that?
>> Okay. Well, I'm curious. So, what else
do you grow?
>> Well, this year, not much, but last year
I had carrots,
uh, okra, I had beets. I had so many
beets, I didn't know what to do with
them. I had um, the other some onions,
the small green onions. Grew those. And,
uh, oh, charred kale. But those are not
for fermenting because they do not do
well at all. That's just strictly for
salads.
And I think that was kind of it. There
might have been more. Can't remember.
>> Wow. Very good. And then could you speak
to um doing garlic, what you do with the
garlic in order to keep it because you
know there's um people don't understand
that if they put garlic in the
refrigerator and it happens to raw, it
can actually become toxic.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I you know
>> Yeah. You just ferment your garlic.
>> Yeah, you just make a salt brine and put
the garlic in it. I have a recipe, but
it's not right here in front of me. Uh,
and I eat the garlic plain or I cook
with it. You can do everything with it
just like you would if it were just raw
garlic in your fridge. But this is
fermented, so it's going to last a long
time. One of my favorite books for
fermenting.
Donna Schwank is the one. Cultured Food
Life is her
um her name of her site. Cultured Food
Life with Donna Schwank. These are some
of my absolute favorite books for
learning. I learned to to ferment with
her. Not personally, but I'd go on her
site and I would read stuff or I'd watch
her videos.
Culture Food Life. Go there. She's still
around. I checked out this morning. I
haven't gone to her site in a long time,
but really, really like her. She is one
woman who really understands
fermentation and she's fun to um learn
from. But garlic, yeah, ferment it is so
easy. You just make the brine, throw the
garlic in, sit it on the counter a few
days, and then stick it in the fridge.
Perfect.
>> So, if you were going to make a
recommendation for somebody to start
fermenting, what would be the top five
things you would tell them to start
with?
>> I would have them start with kefir
because it's so easy. deeper grains and
milk. That's it. Very, very simple. Then
I'd probably have them, the next one I'd
probably have them do is like the garlic
because you're just making a salt brine
and throwing garlic cloves in there.
It's very, very simple to do. Uh, I'd
probably
kombucha is more timeconuming. It really
does take someone to kind of walk you
through it. Although you can watch
videos online and do your own thing. And
this one is an easy one. Making
sauerkrauts quite easy. I demonstrated
that one time. It just takes a little
bit of time. That's all things easy like
that. Start slow, start simple.
>> So, if you were going to, you know, like
um people people who are working and
they're into convenience, what would be
like five top bases that they would need
to have that were fermented in order to,
you know, shorten the meals making a
meal cycle at home?
I would probably buy fermented food at
the store
>> because there are some good quality
fermented foods that you can buy right
in the store because all of this does
take time. So if you have a heavy
schedule, you're busy, you just don't
have time, buy it at the store. Just
make sure you read the label. Make sure
it's raw. Make sure it's live cultures.
Make sure it's in the refrigerated
section and turn it over. Make sure
nothing's been added on the back. Uh no
sugar added. You know, you can get kefir
at the store, but they have all that
sugar added. Get the plane. That's
perfect. I just buy it personally. And
when I travel, I do I like uh I like to
get kefir when I'm visiting my daughter.
And I love the Maple Hill. So, there's a
store there near her that sells the
Maple Here Hill Kefir. And I always just
go get me a couple of bottles of it and
I have that while I'm there so I don't
have to do without it. That's what I do.
>> Okay, great. Thank you very much.
You're welcome, Key. Thanks for asking.
>> All right, so um Shirley
on Daily with Dagaba YouTube channel is
says she was raised on a hobby farm,
fresh eggs and milk and veggies and
fruit trees. And then um I I'm assuming
she's responding to when do you start a
child on fermented food? And she said
soon as they have tea. And good
afternoon from Vancouver, British
Columbia. Hello Shirley. And also Susie
Vim
first kick. Oh my
>> my dear friend Susie. I just love that
girl.
>> So she said, "Hi. Nice to hear you,
Sherry."
>> Oh, she's such a sweetheart.
>> Yes. And AJ sent in a question. Let me
get back to that. Um,
regarding kombucha, is there alcohol in
it or alcohol
What is that or alcohol in it that a
person should be concerned about?
He drinks it. And also,
>> no, no. As a matter of fact, my son and
I, we have this debate going. I said,
"Listen, there's more alcohol in orange
juice than there is in kombucha." He
didn't believe me. So, he did his own
research and he came back. He said, "All
right, Mom. You're right. What kombucha
will turn into if you leave it sitting
too long in the fridge is vinegar.
Vinegar, but it's a nice vinegar you can
put on your salads. Matter of fact, him
asking that brings up something I would
like to share real quick, and that's as
a guide to how long foods do keep that
have been fermented.
And uh for vegetable fermentss, they'll
keep six to 12 months in your
refrigerator, maybe even longer. You'd
want to open the jar and see how it is.
Maybe even longer. So, they don't
necessarily go bad on a specific date,
but they will continue to ferment very
slowly in the fridge. And over time,
they may become just too soft or too
tangy. But they don't become bad. They
just may not be as palatable.
Dairy or yogurt. Yogurt and kefir about
two to four weeks. Uh because dairy is
more delicate and it has a shorter shelf
life than vegetables. You'll know it's
past its prime if you see visible mold
on the surface and the that visible mold
will be visible true mold. You'll know
it's fuzzy stuff. You'll know uh
it may smell changes. Smell may be
different. It might not be that nice
tart smell anymore as smells like
spoiled milk. I tell you I don't keep it
long enough in my fridge for that to
happen. So, I can't say I've ever had it
not ever had it go bad. Now, for miso or
soy sauce or hot sauce, you can keep
them one to two years or longer in your
refrigerator.
Miso paste and traditionally brewed soy
sauce are incredibly stable because of
their high salt content and long
fermentation history. They can sit in
the back of the fridge almost
indefinitely and still be good. kombucha
about one to three months and then it
gets a little bit too vinegary and then
that flavor isn't pleasant to drink but
it's great on a salad. So there you go.
Anything else? I know we're at the top
of the hour.
Yes. Um we are. Um
I think that that was it.
I think you just answered the question.
I was Oh, I did have a question. I
remember.
>> Okay. What is it? Okay.
>> When you're making kombucha, you need
something to start it. What is it? It's
called the mother or something like that
>> called the scobby.
>> Scobby.
>> And that scobby. And that stands for
symbiotic
culture of bacteria and yeast. And it's
a round well depends on what shape you
put it in. If you put it in a square
container to grow it, it's going to be
square when it comes out because it
takes the shape of whatever it was grown
in. It's a scobby and it last um I just
love it. I sent
Rebecca that too, a scobby to start her
her kombucha, but it acts as kind of
like the warehouse that's helping this
the um tea brew because you're using
sweetened tea and that scobby just helps
it kind of brew down below it. It seals
it around the corner. My scobby, I have
a scalloped edge container and the
scobby is scalloped edge because it's
sealing around to keep the oxygen out.
So yeah, scobby seiotic culture of
bacteria and yeast.
>> Very good. And there's alcohol in orange
juice.
>> There is fruit. Well, when you ferment
fruit, it will turn into alcohol very
quickly. Gotcha.
>> And I honestly don't can or don't
ferment fruit. I like the vegetables
more. I like fruit fresh and I like
vegetables fermented.
>> Okay. I just wanted to make sure it
wasn't just like what you bought for I
don't know what
>> I do know that it turned into alcohol
because otherwise you would
>> it takes time. Yeah, it takes time for
it to do that. But it can it can.
>> All right. All right. I think that's all
the questions that I had for right now.
Um and I don't see any other hands up or
questions regarding the show out there
in uh the different platforms. Thank you
so much Sherry. I really enjoyed this
and um you know, thanks for teaching me
how to ferment garlic. That was
interesting and it's still in my fridge.
So um
>> it makes me so happy when I see people
do it.
>> So please just find just add one live
food just one. Even if you have to buy
it and can't make it, do that.
>> Yes, that would be great.
>> All right, I think there might be
another question real quick.
Okay. Um, all right. If I could get my
co-host to join me on the screen, then
we'll um close out the show. Also, I
want to uh also say that if anybody
referred you to this program, please get
back with them because they are going to
be your point of contact and they will
help you with um any questions that you
may have regarding any information here.
And if we didn't if they don't know,
then please email us at
questionsailywithdoc.com.
And um also this program is sponsored by
dailywithdoc.com.
Also we do have a phone team available
if you would like to talk to a certified
holistic health coach and you can call
that number is 855-9493377.
And again, this was for educational
purposes only and not meant to treat,
diagnose, or cure any diseases.
All right, so on the screen we have
Oh, it looks like AJ has we buy kombucha
from Sherry. I knew there was a question
that disappeared on me from the chat.
Asking for a friend.
>> I've been asked that so many times when
people are coming to my classes. Can I
just buy your kombucha? I said, I'm
sorry. No, it's not cost effective to
sell.
>> Okay,
very good.
>> I can't make it on a grand scale like
the commercial people do.
>> Yes, I understand that. But you could
she could teach you how to do it, AJ.
And
>> I I'll teach you how. I'll even send you
a scobby.
>> Oh, see that? She'll send you a scobby.
All right.
>> So, thank you, Sherry. A bunch of people
are saying thank you from the different
platforms. And Zezy Captain says,
"Hello, Albert."
Um, and Olga real quick says, "My
Japanese friend just gave me
gave me selection of homemade miso for
my birthday." That is a true
gift.
>> That's awesome. What a wonderful friend
you had there. All right. So, of course,
we have Sher who was our guest speaker
today and she is amazing and she also is
part of the tech crew and she helped set
up the platforms and everything I send
to her, she sends out to the other
platforms. And so, thank you for all
that you do. I'm pulling double duty
today. And then we have Phyllis who is
out there on the different platforms
posting and bringing in questions
and she is just an amazing um part of
our team. All of the team members are
amazing. But I appreciate you doing that
because when I'm hosting then I know
things are getting disclaimed. So thank
you so much for that. And then we have
Marilyn, who is Miss Speedy Fingers, who
is in here typing almost as fast as we
can talk and she still finds time to
look things up and post without skipping
very much of a beat at all. So, thank
you so much. I find that amazing. And we
have Albert who is out in South Africa.
So, it is nighttime for him. And um he
is our gatekeeper and a true gentleman.
and he lets people in and then if
something is going on that shouldn't be
going on, he kicks them out. Um, and he
also brings questions into the chat and
different things like that. So, thank
you for all that you do, Albert. And AJ
does not have his camera on, but he is
our digital marketing director and he
helps expand on what we already had done
as he pointed out the uh Friday.
So, and just he does a lot of things. We
can't even name everything that he does.
So, every member of this team is
important and Rebecca and I are very
very very grateful for all of you and
also our listening audience out there
and people that come online to to join
the show either on Zoom or like in the
chat. Thank you for everybody who posts
in the chat and participates in the
chats. I really really appreciate you
all. Thank you so much and I hope that
you have a beautiful day and we tomorrow
we have Oh my gosh, who do we have
tomorrow? I want to tell you I think
it's somebody good. I know it is.
Tomorrow we have Dr. Lisa Singleary and
she will be coming on and sharing some
things with us and I really look forward
to that. And Friday we have a very
special surprise guest who I am not
going to announce until tomorrow. Um but
you guys are going to be he was pivotal
pivotal in getting
helping doc sue the FDA and a lot of the
things that we can say right now like
essential fatty acids help prevent and
cure heart disease that they can help
with heart disease.
probably not pure c p c p c p c p c p c
p c p c p c p c p cure but he helped him
say that helped him get um folic acid
and selenium in baby uh formulas. So
very very grateful to this person. All
right. So, have a beautiful day as I was
saying
and um please remember to always be kind
because we don't know what somebody else
is going through. And uh I wish you all
a magnificent day and I will see you
tomorrow. We'll all see you tomorrow.
All right. Bye for now.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics. Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science and Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, Ford
post-doates and pathology, naturopathic
doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics. Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
Ford post-doates and pathology,
naturopathic doctor.